est-ce que sa vie dans la jungle
non est-ce que sa vie dans les grandes
plaines américaines
oui c'est un chat un autre délégué n'y
était géniale pour où il y en a autant
ça fait au moins 35 minutes
qu'est ce qui se passe au papa attention
sur la route sera les marchés
[Applaudissements]
jerry
[Musique]
on fait quoi ça c'est notre porte de
sortie
rochel chery remets toi sur ton siège
rochelle tu me remets tout seul hic
cette fois
[Applaudissements]
ça va chez toi ça va c'est rien ça va
aller allez tout le monde dehors
[Applaudissements]
pour rester dans la rue
mais qu'est ce qu'ils sont guéris caisse
question
copycat
gasquet
[Applaudissements]
rien
à
pas
[Applaudissements]